estamos en este momento en puerto
resistencia el que ha sido uno de los
puntos de bloqueo más importante de la
ciudad de cali desde el paro nacional
que empezó el pasado 28 de abril y que
hoy cumple dos semanas aquí está también
la minga indígena que ha salido de la
universidad del valle para participar en
esta concentración antes de volver hoy
mismo a los territorios del campo por
cuestiones de seguridad después de haber
estado apoyando los bloqueos durante
estos últimos días para destacar que hoy
el presidente iván duque está en cali y
que ha habido una reunión entre
manifestantes de lo que ya se conoce
como unión resistencia que es la unión
de los distintos puntos y el ministro de
defensa y al no estar presente y bando
que los manifestantes han decidido
abandonar la reunión y tendrán otro
encuentro mañana para conseguir una
reunión finalmente el viernes con el
presidente y bando que aquí lo que
estamos pidiendo es la presencia de iván
duque márquez su gabinete de ministros
al igual que un representante al senado
por cada banca necesitamos la presencia
del doctor iván ospina
la gobernadora del valle del cauca
porque porque lo que pudimos observar
hoy es que lo que están haciendo es un
juego con el pueblo colombiano el día de
mañana va a haber una reunión con todos
los comités de todos los puntos de la
ciudad de santiago de cali en la cual
vamos a sacar el folleto y la petición
que vamos a hacer al gobierno nacional y
estatal para que el día viernes tengamos
una reunión con el señor duque